the movie begins at a space station in
Michigan where Kate debiasi a PhD
candidate observes what appears to be a
comet heading towards Earth excitement
fills the air as she brings in her
colleagues including her Mentor
Professor Randall Mindy to share the
discovery they even name the comet after
Kate however their excitement is cut
short as they realize the comet is much
more dangerous than initially thought
when the scientists calculate the
comet's trajectory they discover that it
will hit Earth within 6 months time
causing a global Extinction to raise a
awareness about the imminent danger
Randall and Kate reach out to NASA and
talk to Dr Teddy oglethorp the head of
the defense coordination office they aim
to convey that this comet is a Planet
Killer and within 6 months it poses a
catastrophic threat to all life on Earth
considering the urgency of the situation
Dr Teddy instructs them to come to DC
and arrange a meeting with President
Janie oron the stress of this discovery
takes a toll on Kate leading her to
vomit and turn to substance use as a way
to cope with her overwhelming stress the
following morning Kate and Randall take
the first flight to DC and arrive at the
White House however they are left to
wait the whole day as the president is
busy covering a scandal of one of her
Associates following an unsuccessful day
of waiting for an opportunity to speak
with the president Randall and Kate find
themselves compelled to wait until the
next day they are sent to a motel where
both of them call their loved ones to
divert their mind from an impending doom
Kate engages in communication with her
boyfriend philli with whom she shares a
somewhat strained relationship primar
due to her reluctance to spend time with
his mother in contrast Randall is
married to June and the couple has two
adult sons the following day Kate
Randall and Teddy finally get to meet
the president and her Chief of Staff
Jason who also happens to be her son
despite Randall and Kate emphasizing the
imminent and severe threat posed by the
comet named Comet debiasi after Kate's
initial observation Janie and Jason
remain indifferent they downplay the
danger citing the statistical
uncertainty and refusing to treat it as
a legitimate threat unless the data
reaches 100% certainty they express that
they regularly receive monthly end of
the world warnings with explanations
ranging from economic collapses to
potential nuclear crisis frustrated by
the lack of action from the White House
Teddy urges Randall and Kate to consider
leaking this crucial information to the
press in Silicon Valley the scene shifts
to a presentation by The prominent tech
company bash where CEO Peter iseral
unveils the latest update to the
company's product Li Li is designed to
detect people's emotions and tailor its
approach to appeal to them ultimately
serving the company's interests in
selling products however it becomes
evident that Peter is not only
presenting a technological advancement
but also displaying a callous and
indifferent attitude moments after his
presentation he gets the news about the
comet by his associates in the meantime
Randall and Kate secure a meeting with
the New York Herald the staff confirm
their comic Claim by communicating with
NASA and agreeing to publish a story
about the impending doom however Randall
and Kate are first told to sit for an
interview on a morning talk show with
renowned television personalities Bri
ofan and Jack Bremer prior to their
segment to reveal the comet Story the
broadcast features pop star Riley beina
discussing her highly publicized breakup
with fellow musician DJ cello however in
a live chat the two reconcile and Riley
accepts DJ Cello's marriage proposal
following this Randall and Kate go on
air with Randall maintaining his
composure however they are again met
with apathy when Bri and Jack failed to
take the comet story seriously Kate
frustrated by Bri and Jack's nonchalant
attitude towards the imminent
catastrophe loses her cool on live
television she completely loses her
temper and loudly declares to the
viewers that they are all destined to
die after the disastrous
interview Kate becomes an internet meme
due to her doomsday declarations which
leave people feeling down meanwhile
Randall gains popularity due to his
attractive appearance however they are
told by the staff at the New York heral
that they will not be publishing the
story apparently there were no
substantial views on their recent
interview the staff reject Randall and
Kate's plea citing that the head of NASA
believes the data on the comet story to
be inaccurate Randall and Kate are even
more annoyed only to realize that the
head of NASA is not even an astronomer
but one of the donors working for the
president the situation takes a turn for
the worse when Kate's boyfriend Phillip
who happens to be a journalist seizes
the opportunity of Kate going viral and
pens an article revealing details about
their past romantic involvement
devastated Kate interprets this
Revelation as a heartbreaking breakup in
the meantime Randall finds himself
unable to resist social media he engages
in heated arguments with anyone
questioning his scientific expertise and
gets entangled in discussions
surrounding various conspiracy theories
however not long after the two learn
about the president's Scandal involving
the exposure of her private parts her
pictures are becoming a subject of memes
and shared all over the Internet one day
Randall and Kate are unexpectedly
arrested by FBI agents they are brought
to the White House for a meeting with
President Janie it becomes apparent that
Janie caught in a scandal herself sees
an opportunity to divert attention from
her own issues by using the comet
situation she apologizes to Randall and
Kate for initially downplaying the grave
situation she then agrees to pursue a
mission led by respected war hero
Benedict dras to launch a nuclear strike
on the comet following this Randall and
Kate begin to appear in many interviews
TV shows and magazine covers explaining
about the incoming Comet as news of the
comet's impact and the high stakes
Mission spreads Randall enters into an
affair with brie the TV host on the
morning talk show the day of the Nuclear
Strike arrives and the whole nation
watches anxiously as Benedict and his
team are launched into space to confront
the comet everybody is celebrating the
fact that the planet will be saved soon
however during a briefing where
president Janie meets with Randall Kate
Bri Teddy and other officials Peter the
tech billionaire interrupts to share
crucial information with Janie moments
later it becomes apparent that Benedict
and his team are retreating from space
pulling back toward Earth and
effectively aborting the mission the
unexpected turn of events only adds
uncertainty and tension to the comic
crisis soon after Randall and Kate find
themselves in a shocking Revelation
during a meeting with Janie and her
staff Peter driven by the prospect of
substantial wealth and material gains
for big companies including his own
suggests allowing the comet to strike
Earth it is revealed that the comet is
full of rich and Rare Minerals that
technology manufacturers use in phones
and laptops Peter who also turns out to
be one of the president's donors asserts
that they must capitalize on such
resources to get the upper hand on the
world economy leaving their Rivals like
China behind he further Reveals His plan
to use his technology to fragment the
approaching Comet and collect the pieces
from the ocean to mine them later
understandably both Randall and Kate are
horrified by this profit-driven
perspective they protest against Peter's
plan to use technology proposed by his
company bash and esap scheme that has
not undergone peer review however their
plea falls on dumb ears as the White
House agrees to commercially exploit the
conet by first letting it enter the
Earth's atmosphere unable to keep it to
herself Kate later announces in front of
the public that the White House has
approved a plan that will allow the rich
to be richer while keeping everybody's
lives at stake following this a series
of riots ensues around the city and Kate
is once again caught by the FBI she is
then forced to sign a paper indicating
that she isn't allowed to share critical
information with the public after this
factions across the country begin to
support the government's plan viewing it
as a potential source of employment for
those in need meanwhile those advocating
to prevent the comet strike are
belittled even Kate's parents distance
themselves from her due to their promet
stance they believe the government's
plan will allow them to have jobs and
earn some money Kate then takes a job at
a supermarket where she meets an
anti-government activist named Ule in
the meantime Randall who has been
promoted as a science adviser to the
president supports his collaboration
with the White House Administration and
maintains his affair with brie however
the situation takes a toll on Randall
especially after he discovers Peter's
plan to use bash drones to mine the
comet when he examines the drones it
finally Dawns upon him that Peter and
the government are not going to save the
world this Revelation prompts a change
of heart in Randall leading to a
dramatic meltdown on bri and Jack's show
he criticizes the White House and
condemns The public's reaction to the
crisis in the midst of this breakdown
June Randall's wife discovers about
about her husband's cheating scandal she
lashes out at him by throwing all of his
medications at him as the comet draws
closer to Earth's atmosphere Kate
reconciles with Randall and Ule joins
them in their efforts to address the
impending catastrophe however despite
their warnings about the imminent danger
president Janie and her Administration
decide to host a concert featuring Riley
and cello performing a ballad title just
look up this goes against Randall and
Kate's urgent mission to seek help from
other nations Janie and her staff go on
further to divert funding from countries
like India Russia and China to proceed
with their mining Mission they rather
emphasized their prioritization of
profit over global collaboration As Time
rapidly goes by and the chances of
fighting against the impending disaster
narrow Randall gathers with his family
his wife June forgives him and their two
sons warmly welcome him home Kate Teddy
and youu also join them to share a final
meal together in the meantime Janie and
Peter launched the bash technology
drones to Kickstart their plan tonight
however the drones sent to mine the
comet face challenges as they start to
break down as soon as reaching the
surface of the Comet seeing this both
Janie and Peter come to the realization
that their efforts are in vain in a
moment of desperation Janie and Peter
excuse themselves from the room and
escaped the building now boarding a
shuttle Janie calls Randall to inform
him that there is space for him and a
guest on a shuttle reserved for the
wealthy the shuttle is equipped with
cryon to escape the comet's impact
despite this opportunity Randall chooses
to stay with his loved ones he then
wishes she would take care of Jason and
the administration when they reach a
safe place this is when Janie realizes
she left her son back in the building as
the comic clears Earth's atmosphere and
races toward the ground Randall and the
others reflect on the richness of their
lives before the impact soon the
inevitable destruction of Earth unfolds
and in the final moments they reflect on
the good times just before the
devastating impact of the Comet takes
everything away in a mid-credit scene
the 2,000 people who escaped Earth
before the comet's impact land on a
vibrant alien planet after 20 2
2,740 years in cryopods they get out of
their spacecraft in a state of awe naked
admiring the habitable world around them
however their Joy is abruptly shattered
when Janie is unexpectedly killed by a
bird-like predator habituating the
entire planet back on Earth it is
revealed that Jason Jan's forgotten son
somehow managed to survive the comet's
impact he records a video of himself
declaring himself the last man on Earth
and urges any remaining viewers to like
And subscribe